hi everyone my name is Jessica Donal I'm
Laureen take and wait here for another
week of hasta Paris today we're gonna
get into some more lucious because you
guys have been really keen for us to
keep trucking on with this one
don't come in you quick can use all that
so you can use some everything to to
wipe
morning boss
so this guy on the bench I guess it's
the way I was saying no you cannot use
Oh what we're gonna strap oh that's
right so we're actually going to betray
our grandpa he's the only person that
supports a satanic lifestyle this game
is a weird because we don't have an
antagonist cuz we are the antagonists
that's true actually I never thought
about it that way there's like five
people walking trumping around the house
and one of them's coming back in here yo
yo yo yo pop [ __ ] he doesn't pause oh
wow did not know that huh
god damn it Susan are you gonna open the
door first I'm running out of time
No shut up nice okay Oh what d'Alene was
just like flashing you've inspired oh my
god you did so well this whole street is
just gonna be this con savings game so
it's just like mm-hmm
so many people in this whole way Oh like
over laughing hey that's good cuz that
means they weren't control down in if
they just stuck there forever
ya know I clicked for like I was gonna I
was maybe you leave me no time I love it
when I take over is this [ __ ] section
save like Juno at me like it doesn't
even give me a chance like my mum is
like the one that you come be spotted by
get out damn woman
just trying to have a satanic ritual and
fix my demon ball so I can move on with
my life I need to make that noise no no
yellow Sanchez on Twitter has a damn you
Suzanne you idiot no one likes you
that's really hard
oh my god no why why why that doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense
seriously that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense like that's not like a bug in the
game 100% like why it doesn't give me
any time to click the button like
sometimes it does sometimes it does
- Adi says it's a six on the annoying
scale honestly maybe a seven if he was
playing it on streem 9 oh your game
no I can't do this again I can't [ __ ]
do this again all right dude I'm into my
[ __ ] rape move mother is a rage again
oh you [ __ ] you didn't notice for me
you absolute absolute [ __ ]
this game makes me want to rip out my
eyeballs
your wife just got a little scared
quick do the wifey wife and then foster
hopefully oh they recover so quickly yes
don't jinx me woman no yeah I got the
diamond plates what else you want
hello boy you know what'd be funny oh
there we go in the ground
if it's oh my god I would weep hopefully
guys I will split his innards into these
four balls and then it will give me a
[ __ ] save and we can move on let's
see I marry you he was blocking this
maybe there's something in here ah oh no
you're right that's why it's called
backstabbing like this chapter oh yeah
murder murder guys I was gonna give up
who would have thought a little boy be
capable doing that
no don't key on you well that's one ball
taking care of hue more people yeah
roughly we have no grandparents you
break free of the straw no put your
straps back on okay let's just calm down
and try to figure out what happened to
you well I don't know
oh god I'm gonna say I'm on fire
you don't wanna talk oh he can make this
do that hey no don't spin the cross no
really [ __ ] you like what you do now
you're on top of him well you want you
taking breaks no meaning to it's like
still trying to turn it again [ __ ] he
stabbed me I died right away
look at me I know an actual little boy
ahh oh my god that amazement of that
well done my crucifixes the crucifixes
in my house will go the way that I want
them to go
I think he's dead little one I think
he's dead
invocations to Satan oh just some light
reading together it's the only
explanation I can find you're onto me if
your father starts telling you something
he wants me to I hate her oh very good
I know I think I am the best I am the
best I am humble I was just gonna turn
this around it's too good I know our
next subject is [ __ ] you don't tell me
what isn't even a biology book
22-caliber combined can you imagine
saying that it's a real ad combined
combined goodbye Jack Michaels we hardly
knew you I feel like competitive awesome
this is won't list for this yeah
oh that was a weird trap
and there goes his brain hole the
Susan's going down
Susan is going down finally oh I got me
an iron and it's also hanging from my
hands that's why it looks very strange
okay it's in there yeah I got it this
game is such a mix of satisfaction and
defeat yeah there's an iron in there
can't wash any more clothes she's going
to take a shower oh good this is when we
get to kill someone in the shower oh my
god are we going to see more are we
gonna do the homes good I wouldn't be
surprised that was naked ready for naked
oh wait oh the head drive the heads
right I really can he knows everything
isn't it yeah miss I've dropped the head
Riya oh my god come back here you
definitely hit a dryer we have to stare
this naked woman forever oh here we go
oh it's a nasty way to go was a lot of
what that was yeah that was lucious we
are one playthrough from finishing it we
got through the super annoying stealth
pot hopefully there won't be too many
more but um yeah like let us know if you
want to see the end of it you'll
probably see the end of it anyways who
played it this long but um yeah let us
know if you like this if you didn't if
you want to see something else we can
certainly do that whether it's something
we play before completely new leave us
your comments and
yeah we'll be we'll be back as we tend
to be thank you see you next time thanks
same time next week bye